Whoever said we're getting rid of the video white tummy,
tell me. No, we didn't.
You tell me.
Whoever said we're getting rid of the video white tummy.
So stop the crap.
Stop the nonsense,
stop the hysteria.
Let me tell you, Sunshine,
I used to go to the barrage
where the hell have been called teacummer and political
and respect and not.
You shall see what I mean.
See, get an education,
get some manners.
You have plenty of time.
You have all these people speaking here.
You see what I mean? Today
I've heard people say that we are spiders on the side
that we are sandflies.
I'm sorry to say, folks,
not even Donald Trump is calling his opponents
insects yet.
And those people who think they can change those basic
facts by singing over me,
I got news for you.
There's people up and down country watching you
and they're asking
why do those people have a right to stop?
The rest of New Zealand debating its own future?
News flash, you were booed,
drowned out by wire said.
Do you think you actually achieved anything here today?
Well, absolutely.
I delivered the message I came to deliver.
And a small minority of people,
you'll notice the actual host,
we're all listening, misbehave.
But you know,
I think New Zealanders can make up their own mind.
Does that really change the importance of a message
getting across at this point
as Prime Minister and as leader of The coalition,
were you proud of the way that your coalition partners,
your Deputy Prime Minister
has conducted themselves on the MNI today?
Well, they were,
they were there, uh,
speaking and,
as they were invited to do so.
And they're free to speak as that,
as they wish.
And that's up,
and that's up to their individual decision.
As you, as you know,
we're in a coalition government.
Uh, we don't all sound the same.
We don't all say it the same.
Yeah, I'm giving you my opinion, which is,
which is that we don't say it the same.
We won't be the same,
and we will say things differently.
And we actually have enough space to be able to do that.
What we're aligned around is actually the core things
about actually how we improve this country.
And that's actually what a lot of our conversation
with eewee leaders has been about as well.